Welcome back.
Well I'm now going to do just a
bunch of integration by parts
problems, as many as I can do
in ten minutes without
confusing you.
So let me just write the
formula for integration by
parts, and if you ever forget
it-- I mean, it doesn't hurt to
memorize it, but if you ever
forget it-- you just really
have to just derive it from the
product rule of
differentiation.
But it just says that if we
have an integral of f of x
times g prime of x-- so if you
see, within the integral, sign,
one function and then you see
the derivative of another
function, and I think with
practice-- integration by parts
is really a bit of an art.
It's not systematic-- that's g
prime of x-- that equals f of
access times g of x-- this is
how it's the product rule in
reverse-- minus the integral of
the derivative of the first
function, f prime of x,
times the second function.
And it kind of easy to
memorize, because there's this
symmetry to the formula.
So let's see if we
can apply this.
And really, once you know that
you should use integration by
parts, I think you'll find that
it's not that hard to do it.
The hard part is to recognize
when you should use
integration by parts.
From my point of view, it's
kind of my last resort, or once
you have a lot of practice, you
might recognize, well, if
there's an e to the x in it, or
if there's a trig function in
it, and I can't do the reverse
chain rule or integration by
substitution, then integration
by parts is probably my best
option, assuming I'm seeing
this on an exam and
not in real life.
In real life, it might be an
unsolvable integral, and
you'd have to use a computer
or some other technique.
But if you're seeing it on an
exam, you know it's a solvable
integral, and if you can't
solve it any other way, it's
probably integration by parts.
But let's just do
some problems.
Let's say I want to take the
integral of x squared e to dx.
So if I saw this out of the
blue, and I didn't know that
this was a presentation on the
integration by parts, I would
first-- clearly this isn't a
polynomial, so I can't just do
a simple polynomial
antiderivative.
Then I would try to see, is
there the derivative of
something, of one function, of
kind of a composite function
here so I can do the
reverse chain rule.
The derivative of x here is 1,
so I can't do anything here.
So I use the chain rule.
And the way I think about
the chain rule is I
want to simplify it.
So when I go into this term
right here, I'm going to
have to pick up my f of x.
I have to pick my f of x out
of probably one of these two
functions, so that the f
prime of x is simpler.
And I need to pick my g prime
of x, I would guess that either
x squared is going to be my g
prime of x, or e to the x is
going to be my g prime of x,
and I want to pick that so that
when I take the antiderivative
of it, it's going
to be simpler.
Or at least, not
more complicated.
I know that if I take the
derivative of x squared,
that simplifies it.
And I also know that the-- and
once again, this is one of my,
to me, a very mind blowing
idea-- but that the
antiderivative of e to
the x is e to the x.
So it's probably a good idea to
say that f of x is equal to--
it's probably, let me change
colors-- it's probably a good
idea to make f of x is equal to
x squared, because later I'm
going to take the derivative of
it, and the derivative of it
simplifies it, and it's
probably a good idea to make g
prime of x e to the x, because
later, I'm going to take the
antiderivative of it, and the
antiderivative of e to
the x is e to the x.
It's not going to become
any more complicated.
So if we assume what I'm doing
is right, then what did we say?
Well here, we just multiply the
two real functions, right?
So when I say the real
functions, I mean not
the derivatives of
e to one of them.
So f of x, we're saying
f of x is x squared.
Let me try to stay
color consistent.
And we said g of x-- now don't
get confused-- we're saying g
prime of x-- let me write it in
a corner down here-- we're
saying that g prime of x
is equal to e to the x.
And of course, if g prime of x
is equal to ex, then g of x
is also equal to e to the x.
So g of x-- I don't want you
to think that I'm somehow
putting g prime of x here.
I've taken the antiderivative,
it just happens to be
the same function.
And then from that, we subtract
the integral, we take the
derivative of x squared, so you
get 2x, and then times the
antiderivative of g prime of x.
Well, the g prime of x is
e to the x, you take the
antiderivative, it's
still e to the x.
Actually I should probably stay
at least keep the colors kind
of consistent, so you know
what I'm hopefully doing.
The example using e to the x
might be a little complicated,
because it's hard to tell
whether I've taken the
derivative or not.
And you can kind of keep
reverting back to the top
formula if you get confused.
So it looks like I've
simplified it a little bit.
This integral looks easier to
solve than this integral.
But once again, when I look
at this, I'm like, well,
how do I solve this?
I can't use the integration by
substitution, because there's
not an embedded function and
then I have the derivative of
it sitting right
next to it, so.
Maybe I need to do
integration by parts again.
So let's do that.
So let's say-- let me do it
separately-- let's assume-- I
think you getting a little bit
of the hang of it-- along the
same vein, that this is f of x,
that this is f of x, and that
this is g prime of x now.
We're kind of doing
integration by parts within
integration by parts.
So if that is the case, that
this integral is going to
equal-- because we have the
minus sign out front, this
minus sign out front-- this
integral is going to equal f
of x times g of x where
f of x is just 2x.
Our g of x, this is
g prime of x now.
Remember, we're kind of doing
a new problem within the
original big problem.
So this is g prime of x, but
g of x is still just e of x.
I took the
antiderivative of it.
And that's minus the integral
of the derivative of
the first function.
That prime of x.
So that's just 2.
And then the antiderivative
of the second function.
Well, that's easy.
The antiderivative of e to
the x is just e to the x.
Interesting.
Now I think you see
where we're going.
This is actually-- let me
write out the whole thing.
Because this is-- x
squared, e to the x.
Just so we don't lose track
of our original problem.
Interesting.
Now I think we have an
integral that is pretty
straightforward to solve.
Don't want to forget my dx's.
What's the integral of-- we
could take this 2 out of
this, and I think it becomes
pretty obvious-- what's the
integral of e to the x?
This is a scratch-out,
this says dex.
Just so-- and it's
a little messy.
I don't like this color.
Magenta.
Well the integral of e to the
x, or the antiderivative of e
to the x is e to the x, right?
So let's write that.
So I'm going to rewrite
everything we've done it.
So there's x squared e to the x
minus 2xe to the x, and then
this minus, you distribute it
so it becomes a plus, so then
it's plus 2-- I just took the
minus, I multiplied it times
this minus, so I got a plus 2--
and then the antiderivative of
e to the x is just e to the x.
And then of course, we should
never forget the plus c.
Pretty fancy, no?
We've figured out the
antiderivative, the indefinite
integral of x squared e to the
x is this big fancy thing.
I bet you, before listening to
this video, you would never
imagine that you could tackle
integration like this.
You could actually try x to
the n times e to the x.
You can try x to the
tenth times e to the x.
It actually turns out you'll
just have to do this many many
many many times, but every time
you do integration by parts,
that the exponent on the x-term
just becomes smaller and
smaller and smaller until you
get to something that's really
easy to integrate, and then you
can do it, and you'll have kind
of this big long expression.
It might be tedious, it might
be hairy, but at least you have
a tool kit-- or you have
something in your tool kit--
that you can tackle integral
problems like this.
I'll probably do one more video
on integration by parts, just
because I think this is one of
the harder concepts to really
grasp and feel comfortable
with, and then I'll try to
do a bunch of examples.
Maybe not soon, but in the
next couple of weeks, on
just a lot of integration.
And I'm going to mix it up so
that hopefully you can get a
sense of how I try to figure
out which of my integration
tools I should use for a
certain problem when
I see the problem.
See you in the next
presentation.